we're joined by Senator Rand Paul he
serves with Senator Graham II represents
the Commonwealth of Kentucky he's got a
new book out a fantastic new book called
the case against socialism Rand Paul
joins us tonight senator thanks so much
for coming on
thanks Tucker so I don't want to single
out I don't to be you know unfair to any
particular senator but I would tell you
that I hear a lot from our viewers you
know what is the answer how did this
start
Lindsey Graham is the committee chairman
he claimed he would get to the bottom of
it why hasn't he well not just any
senator can do this so I can't call a
committee hearing and drag these people
in senator Graham has the power he's the
chairman of a powerful committee the
Judiciary Committee and yes I've
encouraged him publicly and privately to
do this I'd like to see John Brennan
come in I want to see Brandon testify
and I would ask him very pointedly did
you talk to the British intelligence
agencies and did you set up spying by
foreign intelligence agencies on the
president or the president's campaign
because I think he did and I think
that's against the law
and I've talked to people who are
convinced that these people while they
may be deceitful they're sort of you
know so officious that they probably as
paperwork they filled out and those
phone calls probably have a record but I
think he did call the British agents and
I think he did get them involved but I
also think it'd be interesting to know
Christopher Steele in that steel dossier
did he talk to Russian agents that's
been the rumor for over a year now that
he was getting information from Russian
agents so everything that Democrats have
accused President Trump of doing you
know investigating a political rival
with a foreign country right all of
those same questions should be asked of
the Democrats did they do this wrong
well that's exactly right and we're
being told we have no right to know the
answer after two years of sitting
patiently and listening to this nonsense
about Russia so Lindsey Graham is at the
center of this you want to give him the
benefit of the doubt but the question
remains why hasn't he done this it's
within his power to do it he hasn't done
it what's the answer why you know I
think we'll have to wait and see I think
he does want to get to the bottom of
this but you're right he needs to go
ahead and exercise his power we've been
waiting a long time on this some people
and I'm not going to say senator Graham
but there are other Republican senators
up here whose allegiance is more to the
deep state than it is to the president
yeah I do think that Senator I think the
senator Graham does like the president
wants to get to the bottom of this but a
lot of us want to see it get started we
want to see subpoenas and we don't want
to see everything being done in secret
on the house side and then they parse
out what they want to parse out most of
those people that are testifying over
there could equally be asked to testify
over here but really I want to see
Brennan come in and I want to see so I
see a pattern here though and again I
don't want to be mean to Senator Graham
who I've known for a long time and I
think is smart and capable maybe that's
my frustration as he is smart he is
capable when he goes on cable news not
on this show but on others and he makes
these claims I'm gonna do that so I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that I'm
fighting for you and then he doesn't
here's another example here is Lindsey
Graham promising us voters in America
he's gonna get to the bottom of the raid
on Roger stones house watch my job is to
provide oversight to the Department of
Justice as the Judiciary Chairman
somebody needs to watch those who watch
us Muller do your job but these tactics
are unacceptable given the level of
threat here I'm sending a message to
them you're you're accountable to the
Congress and we're going to find out
well they better answer my letter okay
power them I would okay so he didn't in
the end get to the bottom of the raid on
Roger stones house why shouldn't we feel
aggrieved well he needs to use his cloud
and only he can do it sometimes they
give the argument they say well we only
want to do it if the Democrats will do
it in a bipartisan way but it doesn't
have to be that a simple majority can
vote to do anything in the in the
Judiciary Committee and I think every
one of his members will vote with them
to have hearings but yes I think there
should be very high-profile hearings on
this and there's a lot to investigate
how they originally got the FISA warrant
I want to know that because I don't want
anybody else in America
to be abused by government the way the
president was so I'm wondering if this
is something to do with another issue
unrelated directly to these issues which
is foreign policy senator Graham as you
know is really probably the most
aggressive neocon in the Senate he has
butted heads with the president over
this they're currently arguing about
Syria I wonder if his disagreement with
Trump
on foreign policy questions has caused
him to slow walk some of these
investigations well there is an
establishment both in foreign policy and
also in the intelligence community and
then the telogen community truly is the
deep state the deep state has an
enormous amount of power to look at
individuals and so when Senator Graham
and I have fought these fights in the
back in in the past I've always fought
for having warrants where a real judge
in public has to you have to present
probable cause Lindsey has always fought
for allowing these to be done secretly
these FISA warrants unit allowing
Americans to ended up Americans be
caught up in these and so this is
something that there may be a concern
that if we look at the intelligence
state the deep state that as we find out
things that some of their power may
diminish and so there might be a
philosophical difference that he wants
them to maintain their power he wants to
maintain the the intelligence
community's yeah enormous grip it may be
and I bet you the voters of South
Carolina disagree with him on that and
and I think voters want to know what
happened what they did to the president
yeah senator thanks so much great to see
you tonight appreciate it